well the Trump riots have hit Brazil as
insurrectionists are committing very
similar sorts of acts as what we saw on
January 6 2021 in the United States
demanding the return of former president
jair bolsonaro who is in Florida having
chicken at KFC and walking around a
Publix Supermarket I I know I know we
are going to get to all of it but when
we say the actions of trump and his
cronies following the 2020 election
in part due to the lack of consequences
that they suffered will encourage and
will normalize the same type of behavior
in other places and that is exactly what
we are now seeing in Brazil the
Associated Press reports Pro bolsonaro
rioters storm Brazil's top government
offices we have Incredible video of All
Sorts and it looks like January 6th it
it is a version of January 6 which we
will get to
um AP reporting supporters of former
Brazilian president bolsonaro who
refused to accept his election defeat
stormed Congress you could just replace
Trump and Trump supporters there the
Supreme Court and the presidential
Palace on Sunday a week after the
inauguration of his leftist rival
president Lula thousands of
demonstrators bypassed security
barricades climbed on roofs smashed
windows and invaded all three buildings
which were believed to be largely vacant
on the weekend some of the demonstrators
called for a military intervention wow
where we have we heard that before to
either restore the far-right bolsonaro
to power or oust Lula from the
presidency hours went by before control
of the buildings on brasilia's vast
three powers Square was re-established
with hundreds of the participants
arrested and we're going to talk about
that as well
in a news conference from Sao Paulo Lula
accused bolsonaro of encouraging the
uprising by those he termed fascist
Fanatics and he read a freshly signed
decree for the federal government to
take control of security in the federal
district saying quote there is no
precedent for what they did and these
people need to be punished let's take a
look at some of the stunning stunning
video here is one in which you will see
and let's see if I can get the volume
right
will keep the volume lower in this one
you see folks who have gotten through
the police barricade you quite literally
see the fencing there down on the ground
invaded the Congress ramp they
threatened to occupy the chamber and the
Senate which they subsequently did they
subsequently did these videos different
setting uh different weather that's for
sure but looking very very much like
January 6th here in the United States in
another video continuing to look just
like what we saw on January 6 the
bolsonaristas invaded the floor of the
federal Senate and they're wearing
different clothes you don't see the Q
Anon shaman
but you see a very very similar looking
event as to what we saw on January 6th
in the House of Representatives
[Music]
yeah
the imagery as we continue looking here
is more imagery where you will see and
I'm trying to get the audio mix just
right so you can hear me
this looks like January 6th they have
Flags they approach police they knock
down the barriers in this case police
take out some kind of an irritant spray
it appears
but the Riders uh overwhelmed the police
in the sense that they break the barrier
and they continue moving on into the
buildings
where have we seen this before I mean it
is just another example of the same
thing again now it is really important
to understand
not only how can I say this
in a general sense we know where they
got this idea we know where they got
this idea because we saw it here on
January 6 2021 it's been two years and
three days since that took place but
it's also important to understand
that Bannon Steve Bannon and other Trump
aides were advising jair bolsonaro in
November about how to proceed this is an
article I have on the screen from The
Washington Post the date is November
23rd and we're going to deal with this
in more detail a little bit later
Trump AIDS Bannon Miller advising the
bolsonaros on next steps next steps what
do you mean well you know instigator
Riot an Insurrection some allies and
advisors writes the article want the
Brazilian president to contest his
election loss to Lula others want a
global fight over free speech and you
can read this and we're going to look at
it a little bit more later so I won't
delve into it that much right now but
this is the Playbook they helped them
develop the Playbook and we should not
be surprised when the same inputs give
you very similar outputs now what is
necessary here
is for the military to say
that they unconditionally support Lula
as the legally elected president and you
all know I absolutely despise bolsonaro
and I'm not a big fan of Lula I've I've
told you my issues with Lula before I
think Lula is better than bolsonaro but
that's a separate question from who is
the legally elected president and the
legally elected president is Lula so the
military and maybe by the time we go to
air with this it will have happened I
don't know if it has as of right now it
hasn't happened which is why I'm saying
it the military should say Lula's the
legal president don't come to us for any
sort of ideas about a coup or help with
the Insurrection Lula is the president
period now unfortunately there are many
in the Brazilian military who are very
much anti-lula and when you know that
that's the case until you hear that
unconditional statement of support you
wonder whether it's actually coming this
is in part what happens when the people
who tried this here weren't seriously
punished and by by that I mean the
instigators and the agitators I know Q
Anon Shaman got four years or whatever I
get it
but big picture all the way up to Trump
the people who created this environment
and stimulated exactly what went down
they have not been punished so so this
is what happens one difference arguably
that we're already seeing is that the
mass arrests have started in Brazil now
are they fully capturing all the law
Breakers yet we don't know but scores
have already been arrested after they
showed up and they did this the things
that I showed you doing on show them
doing on video
um and while there were of course
eventually hundreds of arrests here in
the United States at the immediate time
there was not that show of we're
arresting all of you and throwing you
all on a bus and quite literally that's
what's been happening with a lot of
these rioters who quite frankly are
terrorists
um in Brazil and so that's a difference
we'll see if we get a statement from the
military and we'll see where this
ultimately shakes out now in the midst
of all this you might be wondering David
where is
scenaro well he's in Florida eating
chicken at KFC and looking around at a
Publix and that is exactly what I want
to talk about next
you might be saying well uh jair
bolsonaro must be right in there right
he must be right in there with the
insurrectionists and the terrorists and
the Riders saying I support you and
we're going to get this thing back but
that is absolutely not the case
volsonaro and we're quoting the New York
Times here has been holed up thousands
of miles away
in the U.S state of Florida
before departing Brazil the former
president urged his supporters to avoid
violence Jack Nicos wrote this article
for the times it was updated just a few
hours ago when his supporters stormed
Brazil's Congress in presidential
offices on Sunday to protest what they
falsely claimed was a stolen election
jaira bolsonaro was believed to be
thousands of miles away facing various
investigations from his time in office
bolsonaro flew to Florida in late
December with plans to stay for at least
a month he's been in Orlando living in a
rented house owned by a professional
mixed martial arts fighter a few miles
from Disney World
bolsonaro has long questioned the
reliability of Brazil's election systems
without evidence and he refused to
concede unequivocally when he lost in
October to president Lula who took
office on January 1 yet before departing
for Florida in the final days of his
presidency bolsonaro called on his
supporters to avoid violence and
suggested that they move on we live in a
democracy or we don't he said no one
wants an adventure Sunday evening he
criticized the protest saying on Twitter
peaceful demonstrations are part of
democracy but destructions and invasions
of public buildings like what occurred
today were not he also repudiated
president Lulu's comments that bolsonaro
bore some responsibility for the riots
saying that those accusations were
without proof there is some really
really wild video of bolsonaro in
Florida it just it's kafka-esque I know
it's for for the first time in 2023 I'm
pulling the term out it is sort of
kafka-esque here is video of bolsonaro
in a Publix just kind of like looking
around it's it's surreal almost and he
seems to have security with him
there he is
checking out the register
and it kind of looks like security is
checking out for them which is
interesting I mean that seems like an
interesting grocery store experience
you're just like I'd like this yes sir
yes sir right in the cart and then they
they handle it so so bolsonaro can just
look around
pacing aimlessly and at Publix
waves to the person filming uh yeah you
know
uh wow did did you know these granola
bars have four grams of fiber per
serving this is stuff we don't have
these in Brazil just bizarre and of
course the bigger questions here are
about his legal status in the country
I'm not going to pretend to know the
details of bolsonaro's legal status in
the country there's a few different
things that are possibilities and and I
don't know that we necessarily know
commenters in Brazil are saying
bolsonaro is in the U.S on a diplomatic
Visa now of course the Diplomatic Visa
is no longer valid in the sense that he
entered on the Diplomatic Visa in
December when he was still president
he's not currently president
now the question starts to be is he
overstaying the Visa in a sense because
he was on the Diplomatic Visa he's no
longer a diplomat does that make him an
overstayer
it's doubtful that that's classified as
an overstaying Visa visas are usually
valid for a certain period of time and
once that time elapses it starts to
become an overstay if the person hasn't
left or renewed the Visa or obtained a
new Visa or immigrated in some different
way we don't actually know how long
bolsonaro is really planning to stay now
there are people talking about criminal
charges and what happens if bolsonaro is
criminally charged for something and
it's conceivable that that would happen
in that case I would suggest a package
deal extradite him with George Santos
right back to Brazil and let's make sure
that the legal legal system does does
what it's supposed to do but regardless
there's a lot of speculation as to the
legal status and the immigration status
I assure you
the state department is very much aware
of Gyro bolsonaro being in Florida
how he got here and how long he can stay
and I am sure it will all ultimately
shake out but the imagery and I I don't
even know whether at KFC he was doing
crispy strips of the or the bucket of
chicken or what that is reporting I
would certainly like to learn more about
and whether he thought that the coleslaw
uh had Mayo which apparently it doesn't
apparently the coleslaw KFC is
completely vegan much to the surprise of
many no answers to those questions but
you're sort of hanging around while his
supporters are rioting in support of him
in uh in in Brazil so bizarre and wild
stuff and we are going to talk after the
break about the fingerprints that are
all over this Insurrection and you might
not be surprised to hear
that many of those fingerprints are the
Fingerprints of people who worked in and
around the Donald Trump White House so
that'll be after the break Wednesday
January 11th two days from now is the
first David packman show Town Hall of
2023. everyone is invited everyone can
participate and talk to me we will be
handling the uh uh the the platform we
will use for you to talk to me is
Discord you can find our Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord if you are a
website member you will get Priority
Access meaning we'll I'll take more
calls from website members than
non-members but everyone is welcome and
we're going to take calls from everybody
it will be and I I really want to be
clear because people said what's the
date what's the time I'm telling you
right now okay write this down Wednesday
January 11th at 6 PM Eastern Time 3 P.M
Pacific time
the event will stream
and to call you go to davidpackman.com
Discord we will take a quick break and
continue with so much of the news from
the weekend
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
ladies and gentlemen the David packman
show is a community supported program we
do have a membership program at
joinpakman.com which allows you to get
lots of great extra content and it
allows us to fund our operations it is a
very inexpensive thing and a really
great thing to do you get daily access
to the bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
never mind invitations to the exclusive
members only town halls and Priority
Access to the regular Town Halls like
the one scheduled for Wednesday January
11th at 6 PM Eastern sign up at
joinpakman.com and use the coupon code
please no more Trump
please no more Trump that's the coupon
code to get yourself a discount the
Fingerprints of trump cronies are just
all over the Brazilian Insurrection
attempt that is going on we spoke
earlier in the show of the imagery from
Brazil over the last 48 hours which
looks just like the imagery from January
6 2021 in the United States and
Washington D.C protesters with flags
different flags yes breaking down police
barriers and overwhelming police to get
into legislative buildings in the U.S it
was mostly the House of Representatives
in Brazil they were in the Senate the
federal Senate extraordinary
similarities and it's important to go
back and really understand how this all
came to be something that people thought
of doing in this particular way at this
particular time when it happened here in
the United States
the organizers the Insiders the
inspirers were not punished in any real
way oh I know kiwanan Shaman and the
people who uh you know broke a window
they were punished but the people who
were uh fomenting the Insurrection at
the top level at least for now have not
been held accountable we'll see what
happens the January 6 committee which is
now disbanded has submitted its report
we'll see what Merrick Garland decides
about charges but it's not just oh look
they did it in the U.S that's something
we could do as I told you in the earlier
part of the show
Trump aides Steve Bannon and Jason
Miller wait was it Jason Miller or
Stephen Miller
that's actually a good question Jason it
is Jason Miller okay Trump AIDS Stephen
Bannon and Jason Miller were advising
the bolsonaros on what are the next
steps this is an article from November
of 2022 in the Washington Post
uh while tens of thousands of supporters
of bolsonaro Camp outside military
facilities across Brazil to protest his
election loss members of bolsonaro's
inner circle are meeting with advisors
to former president Donald Trump
to discuss next steps Brazilian
Congressman Eduardo bolsonaro the
president's son has visited Florida
since the October 30th vote meeting
Trump at Mar-A-Lago strategizing with
other political allies by phone look at
this he spoke with former Trump
strategist Stephen Bannon who was in
Arizona Helping Kerry Lake about the
power of the pro bolsonaro protests and
potential challenges to the Brazilian
election Bannon said election results
Bannon said sounds pretty similar he
lunched in South Florida with former
Trump campaign spokesman Jason Miller
now CEO of the social media company
getter and discussed online censorship
and Free Speech neither Trump nor
Eduardo bolsonaro responded to requests
for comment and then of course we have
all sorts of interesting videos that we
can look at first we look at Donald
Trump's address to the people of Brazil
this was right before the vote
starting to talk with the same language
it would really be bad for your country
if you let bolsonaro lose and I just
have to say that I'm very proud of your
last vote and we'll be even more proud
of your current vote October 30th right
because you have a chance to elect one
of the Great
people in all of politics and all of
leadership of countries he's respected
by everybody other leaders I can tell
you including myself respect him at the
highest level president bolsonaro he is
doing a fantastic job for your country
he's bringing it back like nobody could
and I just say he has my complete and
total endorsement he's a great man he
loves his country and let him do his job
Brazil is taking a whole new place in
the world you're being respected all
over the world because of your president
Now understand that's the same incorrect
stuff that he would say about himself
The Playbook is identical the world
finally respects the United States under
me Donald Trump no you look at Gallup
polling and other than Russia and Turkey
I believe it was the world respects the
U.S less than than ever under Donald
Trump and similarly the world has mostly
been horrified had mostly been horrified
when President bolsonaro was indeed
president
oh we lost the video
all right
quite a glitch all right well no problem
you get the gist of it we then go to
November 2nd November 2nd when Mike
Lindell also known as Mike pillow the
CEO and founder of my pillow says hey
I'm actually friends with Eduardo
bolsonaro and my cyber guys have been
watching it and it was all rigged it's
the same language here it's all the same
inputs so you end up with the same
output everybody remember we were
watching the Brazil election oh yeah
cyber guys for watching and uh they took
that we know that we know of was 5.1
million votes
and uh through the machines remember
everybody over there as Brandon looks
for that in Brazil I'm friends with
their uh um the president's son Eduardo
barcenero he's also barcenero by the way
it's the same stuff right the machines
my cyber guys five million votes it's
all wacky friend of this
isn't there that Dan he they tried to
get paper put in where at least the
machines would would you'd hit a button
and it would print out a paper copy so
that you could do an audit that got
voted down by the corrupt judges so the
the judges over there voted that down we
don't want a paper trail so they have
peer machines everybody when I say pure
machine there's no paper it's just a tab
boom boom boom boom so whatever that
tells you whatever program's inside
here's who won okay
so it's the exact same stuff that he's
been saying here it's it's the same
Playbook guys it's all the same Bannon
said the same stuff pillow said the same
stuff Trump said the same stuff it's all
the same stuff we go now from November
2nd to November 20th at that point
pillow was ready to make even Bolder
claims which were Brazil's Supreme Court
actually rigged the election he was
ready to be more more bold in his claims
these back off on getting paper
so they they they
um whether they blackmail corrupt
um threatened whatever they did are
these uh convinced some of them let's
say convinced I don't know how they
convinced them to
yeah
um and then we got to November 23rd at
which point Stephen Bannon was straight
up trying to instigate a coup in Brazil
look in the streets of Brazil look at
the great patrons in Brazil that had a
lot of danger to themselves have come
forward or in the streets of Brazil and
quite frankly as much as I love the
bolsonares and Ed water I think is going
to speak tomorrow there's no better man
on this globe than Edward of Boston or
his father in Brazil it's gone beyond
the bolsonarus this is the people saying
no you didn't follow the Constitution
you use these machines use the Judiciary
to shut us down in the media and we're
not going to tolerate it it's going to
be very interesting to see how that
plays out same in the United States you
know the people like Carrie Lake are not
going to give up and I use as a warning
in the great fight that you guys ever in
front of you both for the cultural
issues for the political issues and the
economic issues once they start taking
and digitizing the elections once they
start going to machines where you can't
get paper ballot you don't have proof of
ID you take it away from the precincts
and they start to centralize it in
collection centers that's all done for
one reason dad's to consistently steal
elections so it's the same the same
bullet points same talking points this
is uh the it's it's fascistic rhetoric
and you know that was November 23rd and
listen to Bannon saying it was
interesting Kerry Lake's not going to
give up Carrie Lake's not going to give
up Carrie Lake's not going to give up uh
and indeed she has kept going and going
and going and going despite the fact
that she lost and that's the idea you
don't allow the election results to get
in the way of you taking power because
that's all that matters at the end of
the day it's extraordinarily dangerous
so we're going to move on from the topic
of Brazil for today and we'll continue
to track what happens but but I think
it's important to say that
we need to watch very closely
how or if this is handled differently in
Brazil than it was in the United States
and we saw the the buses busloads of
people getting arrested right away and
that's good
we'll see if the military makes a
broader statement about there's nothing
here Lula's the legal president that's
it we're behind Lula we're going to
track all of it we'll see where the
differences are and subsequently we'll
be able to say what the different
outcomes are and the impact on the
country and the U.S we're ripe for
another one of these because the
instigators have not been punished uh
we'll see if Brazil handles it in a
different way hey guys uh I don't know
how Joe Biden did this but there are
more people working in the United States
today than at any previous time in the
history of the country if you can
believe that Obama now
this is of course Very tongue-in-cheek
but it is also true if you're new to
this show
I I really want you to pay special
attention to this segment because this
is actually I I really want to do this
the right way okay we started seeing
headlines late last week like this one
record number of Americans employed in
December
159 million 244
000 record number of Americans employed
in December now this is one of my
favorite political footballs depending
on whether you want to argue the economy
is good or the economy is bad for
politically partisan reasons you can
very often use phrases like there are
more Americans than ever currently
working or there are more Americans than
ever currently not working or you can go
away from the number and talk about the
percentage you can say the labor
participation rate is higher than ever
or the rate is lower than ever okay this
is all basically BS in a vacuum so let's
really break down what's going on here
in the United States the population
continues to increase and so if over
time there's an average labor
participation rate let's just call it 60
okay one of the things that will be true
is that the number of people working and
the number of people not working will
both be at record highs think through
the numbers it's very simple in a
country of a hundred million people with
a 60 labor participation rate you would
have 60 million people working and 40
million people not working great
time goes by you get to 200 million
people in the population that 60 labor
participation right now means wow we
have 120 million people working we have
a record number of people working but we
also have 80 million people not working
we have a record number of people not
working is the economy good or is the
economy bad I don't know depends who who
what what point you want to make or what
you want to justify so it's not actually
a great indicator of how the economy is
doing but what's ironic what's funny
what's interesting is that Republicans
love to take either the number of people
working
or the labor participation rate out of
context to make the case that the
economy is good or bad now let me show
you a couple of different things here
this is a chart of the labor
participation rate as you can see this
goes back before 1950. I'll describe it
to you it's not as high as it's ever
been right now the labor participation
rate is between 62 and 63 percent in the
late 90s early 2000s the labor
participation rate was 67 so right now
if you are one of the politically
partisan people that wants to say the
economy is bad you go we are a full Five
Points lower in terms of the labor
participation rate than we were 20 years
ago it's terrible right now okay that's
one perspective however if instead of
looking at the rate we look at the
number of people working which is what
that that headline I showed you says you
would accurately be able to say
there are more people than ever working
right now
that being said
you would also have to figure out if
there are more people than ever not
working right now because of the growth
of the population so let me be very real
with you okay
in order to figure out how the economy
is doing you have to look at many
factors and you should be looking at the
employment rate you should be looking at
job creation it's useful to look at
stock market performance to a degree
consumer confidence look at inflation
look at wages look at export import
balance at trade bound there's a bunch
of different things that we would look
at one of the problems with the labor
participation rate or the number of
people working is how it is composed so
a lot of times right-wingers love to say
the unemployment rate isn't accurate
because if you stop looking for work you
no longer count as unemployed that's
true but that's always been the case
that was the case when Reagan was
President and those very same
Republicans talked about how great the
unemployment rate was that's always the
case that's a limitation of the of the
measurement the problem with the labor
participation rate is sometimes when
people aren't working it's because the
economy is good I'm going to give you
some examples okay
if you are a High School junior or
senior or in college meaning you're like
between 16 and 22 years old okay if
you're in College full-time in these
numbers you show up as someone who's not
working you show up as you're you're in
the not working part but the reason you
might be able to afford to go to College
full-time is because the economy is good
and your parents work and they don't
need you to work to help feed the family
you could also look at the inverse you
could have a higher labor participation
because all of these people who could be
in college have to work because the
economy's so bad their household with
their parents needs more income
I'll give you another example
stay-at-home parents lower
the labor participation rate but if the
economy were really bad a lot of those
stay-at-home parents would have to go
out and get a job so stay-at-home
parents make this number look worse but
it's a sign that the economy is better
I'll give you another example when
people retire they exit the labor force
they show up on that not working side if
the economy is good more people can
afford to retire if the economy is bad
more of those people who would like to
retire can't they keep working you've
got a higher labor participation but not
because the economy is good because it's
bad so you get the picture it's a very
deceptive number by itself Republicans
love using it what's the truth of the
matter the truth of the matter is the
economy is pretty good right now the
stock market is sort of stabilizing
inflation's coming down job creation
numbers are better than expected
um unemployment's low is it a perfect
economy of course not is there suffering
is there poverty is there hunger of
course there's all of those things but
by the metrics we normally use the
economy is doing pretty well now one one
last thing on this Joe Biden's approval
rating does seem to be responding to a
lot of different things but it's
basically been an increasing approval
rating since late July for Joe Biden so
late July Biden's approval bottomed out
it then spiked by early September and
it's been just like a slow burn increase
to close to 44 is 44 an amazing approval
rating no in the modern era of hyper
partisanship is it a typical approval
rating for a president who's doing the
job well enough yeah it's sad that our
standards are that low but it is it's uh
certainly no disaster and it will be
interesting to see how that impacts the
coming to year so more people than ever
working is it the be all end-all of
judging the economy it is not but I hope
you all give me credit I don't play the
partisan games with the labor force
participation rate
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show we are now
ready to talk about the disastrous and
humiliating aftermath of the house
Speaker Fiasco now I don't know how many
of you followed it closely over the
weekend I I did not after a vote number
seven I guess on Friday or whatever day
it was I just checked out and said I'm
sure by Monday we'll we will have
figured out what happened and indeed we
have
um Kevin McCarthy was indeed elected
Speaker of the House eventually on the
15th round of voting in and it all
became a farce it all became a joke
there was a physical altercation on the
house floor in which Republican members
were grabbing each other it's it's
completely surreal that this is what
happened uh Marjorie Taylor green now as
a result is like abandoning Q Anon and
then the Q Anon people are furious with
Marjorie Taylor green it's there's four
or five or six different layers of
absurdity that now are following what
happened on the floor of the House of
Representatives but they have a speaker
okay and it's Kevin McCarthy and one of
the things we have to recognize and I I
mean ideally they would recognize it in
the Republican party I'm not sure they
do
is that they have weakened the
speakership to its weakest Point
certainly in decades in the decades that
uh uh many of us have been following
politics people who are roughly my age
uh this is now a speakership that is
more of a joke than it has ever been
before this is a speakership that is
weaker in terms of its ability and uh
Power at coalescing consensus between
even their own party and you don't need
to look very far to see how quickly this
entire thing became a joke shortly after
the big win for Kevin McCarthy he
announced the very first thing that they
would be doing and listen to what it was
I know the night is late
but when we come back our very first
bill
will appeal the funding for 87 000.
and there's Marjorie Taylor green
clapping
yeah very like just painfully stupid now
I've already debunked the whole thing
about the IRS agents it's I'm not going
to do it now because it's not the point
but we have so many different and
important issues in this country that we
could be working towards fixing and the
idea that the American people would even
remotely benefit from that as opposed to
anything else is laughable one other
funny moment when it was announced that
Donald Trump got one vote during one of
the votes for speaker I believe it was
Matt Gates the entire room just laughs
The Honorable Donald J Trump of the
State of Florida has received one
yeah it really is a joke the the entire
thing has turned into a joke and
obviously it was also political drama of
the highest order it got clicks it got
ratings but the entire speaker Fiasco
really at the end of the day is an
exercising extreme irony and one of our
subreddit users wrong sir are wrong
pointed out a lot of the ways in which
this was extraordinarily ironic so I'm
going to use their post as a jumping off
point here to talk more about this the
20 house members who initially defected
for lack of a better term
in a way they are the ones standing by
their principles in the sense that they
are some of the most insane and extreme
members of the House Kevin McCarthy was
very much willing to trade votes for
power or influence and he did it based
on what we've been told with committee
assignments and with other things those
20 to the extent that they stuck it out
they weren't willing to trade
assignments or whatever for votes
because they thought that Kevin McCarthy
was a terrible candidate now the reason
they thought that is because McCarthy
isn't nearly as Extreme as they are
right so we have to understand that's
really Bonkers but they at least had
some principle principle where so many
of these these other people have
absolutely no principles whatsoever
that's been a theme of The Last many
years these Republicans sort of claimed
to have values
but they really don't it's whatever
values are convenient to them at the
time and as soon as those values are
inconvenient or inconsistent with
getting what they need in terms of power
they abandon the values we saw this 180
that Marjorie Taylor green did Marjorie
Taylor green after years of portraying
herself as I'm anti-establishment I'm
not a sellout I'm against rhinos all of
this stuff she does a 180 and she
supports Kevin McCarthy who is the
Republican establishment because it
seems as though McCarthy promised her a
sliver of influence if he wins and she's
going to get back on some committee
assignments and whatever else the case
may be that's extraordinarily ironic and
another example of how they don't really
have principles Marjorie Taylor Green's
principles are really the creation of a
character that she believes will be a
character that can gain power and
influence also Marjorie Taylor green has
been criticizing defecting Republicans
for not playing ball and wanting
attention but that's exactly what
Marjorie Taylor green did to get herself
to where she is now she has been the
epitome of the attention seeker and now
she's criticizing others for trying to
get attention we're going to look at an
interview later in which Marjorie Taylor
green actually says this you know all
these holdouts were just trying to get
attention
well everything you've done has been to
get attention
and now all of a sudden you're getting
attention because you say that they are
doing the wrong thing and you're doing
the right thing and then Kevin McCarthy
of course by appeasing Marjorie Taylor
green now creates a generation of
Marjorie Taylor green wannabes in
Congress who will make a show out of
obstructing as much as possible and then
eventually coming to the table getting
something some crumbs in the
negotiations and subsequently getting
power first you yell you yell you yell
to get attention then you say well
you're going to want to make me go away
give me some power and so now that's
going to encourage more and more people
to do that
um and then lastly as again as pointed
out by this user on our subreddit wrong
sir wrong
for years and years McCarthy groveled to
Trump he wanted Trump to endorse him for
the speakership groveling groveling
Trump did the endorsement sort of
half-heartedly at the end of the day if
we're honest but Trump did the
endorsement but it turns out that that
endorsement didn't even get McCarthy the
speakership Trump did the endorsement on
I think it was Wednesday night and many
many more votes in which McCarthy lost
eventually it was a different sort of
negotiation that got McCarthy the
speakership so it's another sign of how
through his endorsement we actually
noticed that Trump is even more weakened
than we previously thought
uh and it's irony all the way down quite
frankly this is a very inauspicious
start for the next two years and we know
they're going to go after Joe Biden we
know they're going to go after Hunter
Biden we know they're going to obstruct
everything they can and so now Democrats
are going to have to think long and hard
to use Donald Trump's phrase
um about what is the best way to get the
most possible out of the next two years
and to mitigate damage to the extent
that they can Donald Trump seemingly
extraordinarily impaired and Confused
gave a speech to guests at Mar-A-Lago
and seems so disconnected from reality
that it's hard to know what is going on
in his brain if anything it may be the
sort of situation where you know the
wheel is spinning but the hamsters have
long died and flown off of the wheel I
don't know here is Donald Trump claiming
that Joe Biden convinced Vladimir Putin
the president of Russia to invest invade
the nation of Ukraine what when did that
conversation even reportedly take place
listen to Trump and I apologize the
audio is not exactly perfect Trust of
everyone's mind the power is so
destructive that we won't talk about it
I brought in professors during the
debate I brought in professors uh I want
to talk about nuclear case and Chippy
and I brought him in from MIT I said how
would you respond when we start talking
about death where they said sir sir do
the best you can to not talk about it
it's something you really can't talk
about it's so destructive it's so
powerful the world will be gone and now
I hear this and we have a man
who has no mind left and his mind in
prime time wasn't any good but he has no
mind left and this is the guy
negotiating for us we have a man that
convinced Putin to go into music because
if you look at the psychology that he
used it's the exact opposite Putin would
have never ever gone and he knew the
ramifications do you remember when Biden
said well they might take some small
parts of Ukraine that was that's what
Putin wanted to hear
there'll be no problem if you think some
parts of Ukraine delusional but
dangerously so and I also I I don't
really know what goes on at Mar-A-Lago
I'm going to be down there in a couple
weeks uh maybe I'll drive over and see
if I can figure out what the hell is
going on at Mar-A-Lago but in all
seriousness
I don't even know if the guests are
always expecting to hear this type of
insanity from Trump sometimes it seems
like he's just supposed to be
congratulating someone on a wedding or
something like that not at this
particular event Donald Trump also
attempted to rewrite history in this
very strange speech
um trying to rewrite history about
Ashley Babbitt the woman who was who was
killed at the January 6th Insurrection
listen to this it's what's happening to
our country uh Ashley Babbitt's mother
was arrested yesterday because she was
protesting the death of her daughter
being shot by a lunatic got a record of
not so good and then they try and
protect him and they do things with what
they've done to that family but they
shot her there was no reason and then
they arrested because the mother was in
a group and they arrested yesterday the
mother of Ashley Babbitt so she loses
her daughter and then on top of it she
gets arrested and we uh I can let this
go on yeah now
shot by a lunatic Ashley Babbitt did not
nothing wrong I I want to remind all of
you Ashley Babbitt was the 35 year old
Air Force veteran who was fatally shot
while she was participating in the
Insurrection on January 6 2021 in
Washington D.C she was part of a group
of trump supporters who reached the
Capitol Building during that attempt at
certifying the 2020 election results she
was shot by Capitol Police when she was
trying to climb through a broken window
that shooting was investigated now in
every other case these Republicans say
was investigated police did nothing
wrong they were cleared we support the
police he here they aren't satisfied
with the investigation oh what a
surprise here they say despite the
investigation clearing the police
officer she certainly was doing nothing
wrong the shooting was investigated the
officer was cleared of any wrongdoing I
thought they supported the police I
thought they always agreed with the
exonerations of police officers no it's
yet another one of these principles
that's not a principle it's a principle
if the outcome is the outcome they want
and if it's not then it's very very bad
we're going to take a very quick break
and be back with more right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green I've got to give
her credit she's trying to do something
clever she's trying it it's totally
dishonest it's completely disgusting
it's also totally predictable but it is
clever which is she is trying to very
casually abandon the completely extreme
and delusional elements that she
previously associated with or still did
still does as far as we know including
the Q Anon stuff and the most extreme
elements of Maga and just sort of say ah
you know I kind of got sucked into stuff
but like I voted for Kevin McCarthy now
I'm in I'm part of the Republican
establishment and I'm going to be on
committees and it's all going to be
great and the reason she is doing this
is exactly what I just said she doesn't
want to be the extreme cartoon anymore
she wants to be taken seriously as a
Committee Member in good standing right
up there with Kevin McCarthy with the
speaker of the house and uh adjacent to
power
part of this rewriting of History
started in an interview on Fox News over
the weekend where when Howard Kurtz asks
her about some of her previous you know
associations affiliations Etc she
basically just writes it off and says oh
you know I got sucked into some stuff on
the internet yeah and just to deal with
one bit of History the Democrats
stripped you of your community
assignments after you reacted that was
raw politics but In fairness didn't you
also say around that period that you've
been a follower of Q Anon conspiracy
theories and you had we thought this and
you were no longer uh influenced by the
group well like a lot of people today I
had easily gotten sucked into some
things I'd seen on the internet but that
was dealt with quickly early on I never
campaigned on those things that was not
something I believed in that's not what
I ran for congress on so those are so
far in the past
um you tweeted this is a bold-faced
attempt or a bald-face attempt I go with
both I like both
um to try to excuse
and eliminate and remove her record
which includes she said crazy
anti-semitic things
um she was arguing that the Trump Riders
from January 6 should just be released
at their political prisoners that they
are they're Martyrs of some kind
um she taunted a kid who was traumatized
by gun violence
she went to an event
organized by and at which white
supremacist Nick Fuentes spoke and then
said I don't know anything about it she
accused Nancy Pelosi of trees and Jewish
space lasers on and on and on and on
and now she wants to go ah I saw some
stuff on the internet a lot of people
well it happens to a lot of people but I
didn't run on that stuff I didn't run on
that stuff the reason she's doing it is
that now that they're in power she needs
a different image support the speaker
get onto committees be taken seriously
as a stateswoman of some kind the
problem is you shouldn't be able to and
hopefully she won't be able to just
write off an entire swaths of her
history another clip I'm going to play
for you
um Howard Kurtz says you know a lot of
the people backing McCarthy didn't want
to certify the election is that still
important to the base and she goes
absolutely election denialism she says
is now mainstream Republican party when
things got heated you said this about
congressmanship Roy of Texas he refused
to object on January 6. that's not what
our base wanted so a lot of the people
who were back in Kevin McCarthy also
didn't vote to certify the Electoral
College results for Joe Biden do you
think that's an important thing to the
base even today oh it's it's very
important what I was pointing out is the
same people that conservatives were
holding up in high esteem don't
necessarily have those voting records
while they're at the same time
criticizing Kevin McCarthy who does
Kevin McCarthy did object on January 6
and he's been a top Target of the
Democrats and the January 6th committee
I believe that Joe Biden is a
legitimately elected president of course
Joe Biden's the president that's always
a silly question okay well he's trying
to be silly I was trying to well she
didn't answer the question the question
was is he a legitimately elected
president and she says of course he's
the president so even though she is
trying really hard to distance from q
and on and distance from the conspiracy
theories and whatever when it came down
to it right there she answered about
Biden being a legitimate president the
way they love doing it which is by
saying he is the president which is a
total cop-out and she insists that now
election denialism is part of the base
of the Republican party is it a big
enough base for them to win in 24 we
don't know okay one more clip from this
completely deranged interview uh she
says that a lot of the holdouts from the
speaker vote just wanted attention which
when I think of Congress people who want
attention my mind first goes to Marjorie
Taylor green but now she says others
wanted attention most important thing
that every single member has is their
voting card there's only 222 Republicans
and we need 218 to pass anything that's
where the magic happens and so the big
fight that happened this week I think
that a lot of it was really unnecessary
and just a bunch of fanfare that helps
popularity on the internet but doesn't
produce results now we have a speaker
that we can produce results with and we
have to do that by coming together to
get 218. yeah that's where our power
lies and so with this rules package
let's be very real we've got a Biden
White House we have a
democrat-controlled senate and we got to
get to 218 to accomplish anything right
ultimately Washington it's about the
mask they just wanted attention it was
because they wanted to get popular on
the internet which is the epitome of
Marjorie Taylor green so let's go back
to the beginning
it's dishonest it's absurd it's pathetic
what she's doing but it just might work
she really might be able to rewrite and
remake her image now that they are in
control and that's a very scary thing to
think about the extreme Maga Q Anon
conspiracy lunatics are turning on
Marjorie Taylor green why Marjorie
Taylor green voted for speaker Kevin
McCarthy she also said that the Q Anon
stuff was just something she fell for on
the internet
so now the real hardcore Bonkers people
are Furious here are a couple callers to
the Infowars conspiracy show uh with
which Alex Jones is involved this was a
segment of calls hosted by Owen Shroyer
and people are angry with Marjorie
Taylor green now take a look at this
they are turning on her Tom in
California Tom you're on the air go
ahead go Tom
you know why I had you on speaker I
gotta work
unlike the permanent underclass they're
importing oh you have a job
that's right so well you shouldn't have
a job you big it you know what Klaus
Schwab is going to make sure that you
own nothing
nobody hey I pay taxes so I got a
message
from Taylor green
she has a great
voting record but guess what it doesn't
matter when she knows that her the
policies aren't going to get through
okay so here's the only vote that counts
and that is
she needs to change her vote
today or she's a fraud okay
and she doesn't deserve to come on
Infowars if she doesn't change her vote
today Yep they're turning on her folks
the vote for McCarthy that is it here's
another caller who is all also furious
with McCarthy with Marjorie Taylor green
for voting for McCarthy Josh in Arizona
Josh you're on the Alex Jones Show go
ahead here we go hey man
I just want to Echo what that last guy
said the one that had to make a quick
statement because he was going to work
um I really think that you should ask
Marjorie Taylor green if she's
compromised if they've got something on
her
divorce or someone's going on with that
because you know it just kind of seemed
like there was a major flip-flop with
her it was really weird you know like
she's all this gung-ho and then she's
behind Kevin McCarthy all of a sudden
and he's on the Wes home page as like
the speaker majority I I something's
going on and I just was wondering if you
could do me a favor and actually ask her
Point Blank like do they have something
on her extreme suspicion now of Marjorie
Taylor green the Q Anon people the
Infowars people the frogs are gay people
that follow Alex Jones
um are now turning on Marjory Taylor
green how quickly the tide can turn but
listen obviously if you're Marjorie
Taylor green you're gonna get more power
by being friends with the speaker than
friends with the listeners of Alex Jones
Show that's an absolute uh
unquestionable reality so that is what's
happening and it's funny and sad and
scary all at the same time we have a
voicemail number which is 2192 David P
Karen called in upset that I'm
triggering her dogs now I don't use the
term Karen generically
a viewer named Karen I want to be clear
people might write in and say David I
thought you said you didn't use that
term because it's a racialized term
that's completely correct the caller's
name is literally Karen take a listen
hey David this is Karen from Texas
and we love to watch the show me and my
husband but would you please stop
bumping your microphone it sets my dogs
into a frenzy thank you
yeah I sometimes become so
agitated in my gesticulation that I will
hit the microphone and I don't do it on
purpose I know that particularly for
people listening with certain headphones
it uh very very much is a problem so I
apologize Karen on today's bonus show I
am going to give you the rundown of my
upcoming appearances including with Lex
Friedman
Patrick Bet David and Anthony pompliano
all coming up between now and the end of
the month technically February 1st I
guess
um
Pat producer Pat actually had a complete
breakdown of his internet connection and
Today's Show is being produced in a
coffee shop producer Pat just ordering
Double Espresso after Double Espresso to
be allowed to stay it's crazy what's
going on I'll tell you about it on the
bonus show as well as about my upcoming
appearances get instant access to the
bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yep everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
as bad yeah money is being made on the
bonus show that's exactly right Alex
thank you we will see you on the bonus
show we'll be back tomorrow it's a great
week of programming and of course the
town hall is Wednesday at 6 PM Eastern
and make sure you've slammed that
subscribe button on YouTube pushing us
ever closer to 2 million YouTube
subscribers